6 21 here it is a Wednesday morning as
we've talked about October is Breast
Cancer Awareness Month and many patients
use cannabis to try and manage their
pain this morning is joining us this
morning from angels of Las Vegas so talk
about a partnership with a local
dispensary connected to battling cancer
first of all thank you for joining us
this morning let's talk about angels of
Las Vegas you've been around for a while
now what do you guys do in town thank
you so much for having me today our
organization created to give hope and
support for the children's and adults
going through cancer life-changing
illnesses we provide custom-made wig to
make them feel better about themselves
we also have nutritional care packages
so it could help them with the treatment
and our food pantry is open every
Wednesday for the families when they're
going through treatment so essentially
you're sort of guiding people who are
battling cancer you know whatever it may
be through a really difficult time and
in this case this is a partnership with
the sanctuary dispensary here what is it
doobies for boobies is that the phrase
it doesn't feel weird to say that by the
way uh let's talk about this partnership
yes we were so grateful to be partnering
with the sanctuary so they're creating
this pink strand to the cell is going to
be a portion of it to angels of Las
Vegas and we're grateful for that
because most of our patients you know
canopy has been helping them through
pain management and you know it's been
so holistically helping a lot you find
that when you're helping these cancer
patients get through one of the ways to
manage the pain is with medical cannabis
of some kind yes it sort of eases
whatever whatever they're going through
here so that all leads to you're talking
to this this partnership here there's
also an event happening at Kellogg's Air
Park coming up here let's talk about
that oh 5K so sorry animal coming up
this Saturday also when the community
come out and join us it's going to be
and uh at the at the park and 8 A.M just
join us it's going to be in our website
all the informations too and there you
can see it's October 15th so it's this
weekend over at Cal logs Air Sports
Complex angels of Las Vegas before we go
I also just say we should talk about
just the the amount of of pain and the
challenges of people who are battling
cancer we talk about it so much on on
this program what do you see when you're
in the community you're talking with
patients trying to help them through
what do they need the most the most is
also you know they're going through a
lot of financial difficulties where we
can help them with rent assistance
medical co-pay and they are the family
you know usually the the main family
members going through cancer so the
whole family is affected so our
educational Workshop is helping them so
much we have a weekly and monthly so
it's been you know supported for the
last 12 years so we're grateful to be in
a community it was just like the
sanctuary partnering up with us we're
looking for more businesses to partner
up with us to do this work so we are
grateful to be doing the work to help
our community it's so important when
battling cancer not to do it alone not
to remind people that they're not alone
in organizations like angels of Las
Vegas where helping with that so
appreciate that thank you so much thank
you for joining us this morning thank
you for talking about this event looking
forward to seeing it this weekend thank
you for having me all right